Speaker 1: Let's hear from a few more people
in the audience.
After all, the show is for people in the audience.
It's not for me to sit in a room by myself
with a microphone.
As fun as that could be.
We take calls via discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord.
Okay.
Very, very important slash discord.
Why don't we speak next to Harry from Columbus,
Ohio?
Welcome, Harry.
Speaker 4: David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Thanks.
Taking my call.
Sorry.
I need to jog my memory real quick.
Speaker 1: Also, your audio is atrocious,
and it's like blinking in and out.
It's like a popcorn connection.
Speaker 4: Is it really, really about.
Give me 1/2 to try to address it.
Speaker 2: All right.
Speaker 4: Any better for you, David?
Speaker 1: You know, it's not, but I think
I'll be able to hear your question if you
remember it.
Speaker 4: I do.
So I have a question about and just do the
last first thing I heard about it.
He was.
So what you did neither the Southern strategy.
That was what I had known him for.
Can you tell me a little bit more about him,
like in regards to like, you know, 2000 meals,
even Trump mentioned it recently.
What do you know about Dinesh?
Speaker 1: Well, I know he's a convicted felon
and a grifter.
Know the film.
We've talked about the film, 2000 Meals. 2000
Meals is a film by Dinesh D'Souza, which makes
the argument that on the basis of mobile phone
geolocation data, that's, quite frankly, not
very accurate.
It makes the argument that there were 2000
so-called mules or ballot traffickers who
were making massive dumps of fraudulent ballots
into ballot drop boxes, or, as Trump likes
to call them, drop boxes.
Speaker 2: No more drop.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And it's all completely understandable.
And it's I wouldn't spend too much time honestly
thinking about Dinesh D'Souza.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Then, Brooke, quickly, more substantially,
do you think it will be, you know, successful
for somebody like to get into Ohio politics
for Tim Ryan?
He seems to be kind of tapped to the middle
really hard.
He has an ad that says, you know, Democrats
really messed it up, shipping jobs to China.
But, you know, I'm pro-union.
I'm, you know, pro socially left.
Do you think that can work to win over, you
know, suburban Ohio?
Speaker 1: I think it might.
Yeah, I think it might.
I mean, I think I don't know enough about
the Ohio electorate, but I think it's completely
plausible.
And I support Ryan and I hope he does crush
in November.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
I just don't know how powerful anti-China
messages for my clients.
Speaker 1: I just couldn't bear questioning
by it.
Yeah, we'll have to wait and see what the
result is.
Speaker 2: The Trump talking points.
Speaker 1: All right.
I'm going to let you go.
The connection is just ungodly.
So we will we're going to let you go.
But I appreciate all of the questions there.
A lot of important stuff.